yeah that's a [__] right there we can
get that look
hustle music look look he's smoking on
some overseas Amsterdam [__] cush we buy
the ticket trying to make my plans stick
push me I'm too close to the edge I
smash quick like that dude think you're
getting a couple dollars and switch I
ain't your old model how you know no
positive [__] I'm on some by any means
the [__] got to get rich scheme and
skins my team's only logic is this it's
only one way up to go and that's a part
of this you could you believe they
couldn't see that I was just the [__]
slap I woke them up like in alarm at the
six look I'm a hustler you can tell just
by the course and I did extra features
fully loaded like the bra that I flipped
it's not a ball that I'm gonna spit
there's not a part of my script he want
with me sad sniggers get arrested a
snitch
and to you [__] looking at me like a
lik you could hit we tell you ask the
last [__] buddy resting in piss I mean
no referee for mine see I'm gonna settle
the [__] he start witness says [__]
get arrested and snitch hustle music
getting cares gonna cop that [__] south
central state of mind gonna get that
[__] it's social music mythbuster
Swanson boards on deck out of all we
turn it up and we bought that script
hustle music in this building all money
yeah no money yo get the cash and got
plenty crowd I'm smoking on that good
coming to you look near you soon with
the platoon Swanson boys turnt up [__]
know the business always stay with it
coming full equipped with them big guns
long clips I keep it going strong can't
notice which we keep flowing on some
music turnt up big money big cash all
about that business [__] [__] too
big ass you got a black me out his radio
they still gonna play me though
check it out and subtle music all that
mail gotta y'all got a 16 out of that
man yeah yeah